the iceberg goes deeper in yoshihiro
tagashi's previous series you Hakusho
there is an artifact known as the
chapter black tape and this tape is the
stuff of nightmares it is said to
contain thousands of hours of recorded
human atrocities over a millennia in
fact the content of the tape is so
horrifying that it warps the minds of
those who watch and transforms them into
nihilistic Killers but why is this
relevant well it's because Hunter Hunter
actually has its own chapter black tip
for quite some time it was speculated
that a chapter black tape is what
initially corrupted the Phantom troop
this spawns from a page in chapter 102
where the youthful and happy triplets
were seen playing with a mysterious
videotape the content of which was
unknown we do know the content of that
tape now and it contained an episode of
The Mighty sweep and Power Cleaners a
sort of fusion of Power Rangers and
Captain Planet perfectly Innocent but
the Phantom troop would go on to
encounter another videotape in fact many
more videotapes hundreds potentially
even thousands and the truth of their
content is so horrifying that Togashi
could didn't even draw it on page the
day everything changed for these kids
was when they discovered the body of
their murdered friend sarasa in the
forest her dismembered corpse had been
left with a note a note that crawler
read and refuses to ever speak the words
of but the reason why sarasa was
brutally killed was for entertainment
she was tortured and murdered on film
and in order to figure out who sarasa's
killers were crolo came up with a
sickening plan he essentially turned
meteor City into an underworld safe
space creating specific venues where how
shall we say creatives could screen
there how shall we say films and so the
Phantom troop watched hundreds
potentially even thousands of hours of
humanity at its darkest hoping that they
would one day find sarasa's video to
this day we don't know if the troop ever
found sarasa's Killers but what we do
know is that by watching all of this
content they were morphed and twisted
into the Phantom troop we know today
dark nihilistic torture enthusiasts all
as a result of the hunter hunter version
of the chapter black tape but to lighten
things up here's to go she's standing at
the Eiffel Tower bonjour says Togashi in
perfect francaise to which you say hello
because statistically speaking if you're
watching this video you probably don't
speak French which means that this next
Deep dive might come as a bit of a
bizarre shock to you because tagashi's
inspiration for the Chimera ant actually
spawns from Chimera France specifically
a series of children's books called
Caroline essayami which means Carolyn
and her friends now just who are these
Amis you ask well do the names Pito poof
and yupi ring any bells because all
three of them are featured in these
books first up we have Peter a curious
Panther whose felines was very much
incorporated into the final nefepito
character we also have poof a shot Blanc
or a white cat and one of Caroline's
more intelligent animal friends often
doing the heavy lifting when it comes to
all of the thinking and of course we
have lovable yupi who is a Cocker or a
cocker spaniel in English very much
embodying the more chaotic Derpy energy
of the group much as is reflected in
Hunter Hunter with up his more basic
instinctual nature and in a sense
marowen would be the Caroline of this
group and instead of say Caroline is it
would be marum
de dictator although there's a slightly
more Twisted interpretation as well
because the character of Carolyn does
best some resemblance to komuki both in
terms of age and pigtail aesthetic so in
a weird way the Chimera antar pits
Caroline's friends against her fun thing
though there are books in the series
that don't feature Caroline at all such
as La Noel de puth eup which is a really
trippy book cover to look at having seen
or red Hunter Hunter and it just makes
me think of the ants photoshopped onto
it oof and you'll be decorating the
Christmas tree a new P being a bit of an
explosive rat bag lighting proof's tail
on fire come to think that who gave that
dog matches and why but whatever the
answer is this is only half of the
Chimera ant story with the other half
taking place in Egypt in volume 8
tagashi dedicated four whole pages to
documenting a recent trip he took to
Egypt with his wife and over time
readers of Hunter Hunter would discover
that Egypt had a huge impact on
tagashi's Creative draft so in terms of
time and chronology and such this event
happened before York new started being
published and so you can actually see
hints of Egypt here and there but
nolanov is a mummy but also Finks whose
name is just an anagram of sphinx and
later on Finks would also adopt Egyptian
as guitar during the Chimera antarct and
speaking of the ants this is where they
got the first parts of their names as
each of the royal guard is also named
after an Egyptian deity Montu often
spelled as mintu was taken for yupi
although spelled slightly weirder as men
but Montu was the embodiment of
conquering Vitality he was said to be
the manifestation of the scorching son
of RA which sounds like a very familiar
yupi style attack and Montu is often
associated with Raging Bull strength and
War and all of the fighty stuff so you
shove all of that into a happy French
dog and what we have is menthe then we
have shy a deity designed to embody the
concept of fate and it is said that Shai
determine the span of each person's life
and presided over Judgment of deceased
souls and our shyapoof and that they
kind of did that with spiritual message
allowing control over all of the humans
also he did very much dictate fate as he
was responsible for giving ants
nenabilities with his cocoon although it
is ironic that our shayapoo failed in
his predictions at every turn and
ultimately had no control over his own
death meanwhile nefepito's name comes
from nephotim who was a much less spoken
about God and we actually know very
little about her compared to many of the
more prominent figures but Togashi was
so taken by Egypt that he tries to jam
in a reference wherever he can such as
the cover of volume 20 which depicts how
four protagonists gleefully roaming
through real life Egypt this volume also
featured the most lackluster author
message ever given by Togashi which is a
simple three dots a very bad period in
tagashi's life which we can actually see
worsen in the author comment for volume
21 which is simply I'm just getting by
it's no secret that manga production
combined with health issues has been a
big struggle at times for tagashi but
it's also been a lot of fun at other
times for example Hunter Hunter is
published in weekly Shonen Jump the same
magazine has as one piece which is
relevant because on this occasion all of
the weekly authors got together to do
something fun so this was back in 2018
when one piece was celebrating its 20th
anniversary and to Mark the occasion all
of the current mangaka decided that they
were going to hide a straw hat in their
chapter for the week and for Hunter
Hunter that was chapter 364. although
I'm not sure that tagashi quite
understood the hiding assignment because
during karapika's struggle with Vincent
a straw hat very suddenly and very
obviously appears right above them but
tagashi did have a lot of fun with this
and he admitted to going a little bit
overboard because he didn't just add one
straw hat he actually added a total of
14 different references from a whole ton
of series such as a soccer ball in the
wall Tundra's earrings from Demon Slayer
and even a sneaky equals mc squared
equation referencing Dr Stone however it
is my sad duty to report that all of
these references were removed for the
volume release probably because it was a
consistency nightmare there was so much
wacky crap in that chapter but now when
we gaze upon Vincent's last moments in
this world unfortunately there is no
straw hat to be seen speaking of Vincent
though he may seem like an irrelevant
and very dead bodyguard but he actually
holds a very strange record in Hunter
Hunter well less him and more his
nenability Vincent heartsu is known as
airblow which did exactly what it says
on the box it blows air but like very
powerfully and very annoyingly however
right now eblow is the only none ability
in the series to have been possessed by
three different characters firstly by
Vincent obviously but then during the
fight cropic of stole air blow using
steel chain and then when Vincent was
inevitably killed eblow then passed on
to first prince Benjamin due to his
ability Benjamin baton So within the
roughly 60 seconds that this fight
lasted airblow was passed like a joint
between three different people speaking
of different people though one of the
more enduring different people questions
in the hunt Hunter fanbase is who is
gone's Mother a question that gon
himself doesn't ever care to answer
because he thinks of a different person
Mito as his mother and you know there's
actually a really weird layer of truth
to this albeit only in the 2011 anime in
this series gone is voiced by megamihan
who actually comes from a family of
voice actors in fact her mother is
keikohan best known for her work on the
original Mobile Suit Gundam Saint Seiya
and who just so happens to play Mito
freaks in the 2011 Hunter Hunter anime
alongside her daughter Mega me playing
gone so every time gone and Mito have a
scene there is an unusually genuine
familial connection which is a very rare
opportunity for voice actors to have as
a bit of a sub fact ke Gohan also voiced
Luna in Sailor Moon which I only point
out because yoshihiro tagashi married
naokotakuji who is the author of Sailor
Moon so I guess anime and manga is a
very incestuous industry but Togashi and
takuchi are such a power couple I mean
imagine having a combined career that
spans so long that literal generations
of voice actors are bringing your work
to life and in all of Hunter Hunter
there's only one relationship that
overshadows our two authors and that is
the gone and killer ship the most
popular ship in the entire series there
are many arguments and interpretations
stating that Togashi does layer in some
romantic subtext I'm going to be honest
I'm not here to argue that because
forgetting the fact that they are
literal 12 year olds for a bit it's
actually hard to blame people who think
this way particularly when Hunter Hunter
itself is very aware of this idea and
sometimes even purposely plays into it
so once again I'm gonna call the 2011
anime to the stand because you have some
explaining to do during a hunter pedia
segment of the Greed Island Arc gone out
of absolutely nowhere lushes and states
you can see inside my binder whenever
you want kilowatt which I I don't even
know how that works exactly what is the
binder in this situation I don't know I
you know what I don't want to know all I
know is that the head Canon of the anime
staff may have gone a bit far at times
although no matter how strange the anime
gets it will never be able to rival the
dreams of the fanbase and by dreams on
this occasion I mean literal dreams
seven years ago a devoted Hunter Hunter
Fan was hit with a month straight of
Hunter Hunter dreams and this fan
proceeded to post accounts of 23 of
these dreams on Reddit they start out
innocently enough you know standard
weird dreams that make no sense but then
things take a ton on night six dream six
I was gone I was heading to Beijing with
Pito during the journey she looked at me
smiled and said yeah then I said woof
woof indeed and interestingly these
dreams do have some continuity to them
dream 12. I was gone I became a chimera
ant I was taller have wolves hairs and
insects like articulation I was Stronger
and I get angry against Pito because she
turned me into a chimera ant and just
like tagashi himself sometimes the
dreamer gets distracted and cuts to
something completely different for a
while dream 21. I saw a karapika
fighting in the battle Olympia but he
was weak against the nen users because
they are no spiders he was beaten and
have many bones broken and then the
whole Saga ends very abruptly with our
final night dream 23 I was gone I was
with bisky and kilowatt I have to fight
against Pito but she stabbed me with her
hand then Pito said to bisky and kilowa
that they have to kill some zombie-like
mutants rackets in this place there are
this beings close brackets then she will
heal me but we don't know if Pito ever
healed self-insert Chimera and gone and
we never will but do you know one thing
that isn't a dream though within Hunter
Hunter there is a power system that
exists alongside Nan it's a
significantly more Sinister Force used
by very few but to get into that I'm
afraid that we still need to go one
layer deeper